this is tomohusein reading for reviewer
alessandro barbosa it's surreal to think
that the first lego star wars is inching
closer to two decades old but even more
so to see a brand new version of some of
those same stories in lego star wars the
skywalker saga time has allowed for
significant reinvention developer
traveller's tales lay its marks the
biggest departure from the familiar
formula that has permeated its library
of lego games these gameplay changes
enhance the familiar lego
action-adventure gameplay to make the
moment-to-moment combat platforming and
puzzle solving more engaging however the
breadth of content on offer does not
live up to the potential of this new
direction
core to the skywalker saga's gameplay
changes is a new perspective gone is the
overhead camera replaced by an
over-the-shoulder third-person view that
draws you in closer to effects laden
lightsaber deals and chaotic cantina
shootouts you're offered far more
control over the action than in earlier
lego titles with cover based shooting
giving you more tactical options to take
out stormtroopers and expanded combos
offering more options dismantle droids
with a flurry of melee strikes the
skywalker saga's difficulty is tuned to
ensure you're always making progress its
action is straightforward and breezy
while its puzzles are usually just a
handful of steps away from a solution
rather than throwing difficult
roadblocks in your way it lets you
easily progress even if you're just
repeatedly mashing a single attack it's
still fun to experiment with new button
combinations to see special moves from
the game's expansive roster of
characters but this isn't a game that
requires you to memorize extended combo
strings these mechanics are simply there
for those who want to engage with them
with more than 400 playable star wars
characters there's a lot of space for
many of these to be complete copies of
one another and while there is
significant overlap between the
characters that wield the same category
of weapon a class system creates enough
of a substantial gameplay difference
between similar characters it's easy to
tell the difference between a fast
shooting bounty hunter and a
well-rounded scoundrel as well as the
slight ability difference between force
wielding characters depending on whether
they're sith or jedi each class also
features unique abilities that are
needed for certain puzzles supplying
incentive to swap between characters
when you're exploring planet hubs or
replaying story stages i can certainly
be of assistance here
replacing the collectible red bricks
from previous games are new kyber bricks
which are used in conjunction with the
returning stud currency to upgrade the
skywalker saga's expanded roster of
character types each class has its own
albeit small upgrade tree to pursue
letting you expand on the abilities of
force wielding melee fighters or the
utility of a protocol droid this can
make objects thrown with the force more
deadly for example or make equipped
armor block more damage most of these
unfortunately only work towards removing
the annoyance of many games that wear
out their welcome early in the game
instead of giving you more fun tools to
layer on top of the expanded combat
options given the game's low difficulty
it's also easy to just completely ignore
many of the core upgrades that apply to
all character types considering they do
not have any tangible effects on the way
you will continue playing this makes
hunting for kyber bricks less exciting
unless you crave the missing thrill of
finally uncovering the last one after
breaking apart everything in a level
throughout the 45 levels of the
skywalker saga which is five levels per
movie you'll be swapping between
predetermined character teams to tackle
some of the skywalker saga's best
moments especially in its linear stages
the mix of puzzle solving and effects
laden action is a delight letting you
re-experience some of the highest highs
of the franchise with a humorous veneer
i'll take them myself cover me yes sir
it's clear from the moments included
such as the climactic lightsaber duels
and recognizable death star trench run
that traveller's tails understand star
wars fans both young and old the
skywalker saga has enough silly
slapstick moments to garner countless
giggles from younger plays but it's also
full of clever jokes from other sources
that older players will appreciate a
reference to an ezy izzard skit was a
real highlight some of the most
climactic moments from the film are
played for intricate laughs sometimes
even poking fun at them in the process a
younger anakin in episode 1 is written
as a laughably self-centered brat
quickly moving from one emotional trauma
to the next if it continues his journey
to become a jedi later in the same
campaign the eye-catching fight between
darth maul and jedi pairing of obi-wan
and qui-gon jinn supplies another good
reason to lose yourself in the epic
soundscape of duel of the fates which is
made all the more special if you happen
to notice the hovering platform of a
droid orchestra playing along to the
symphony in the background the skywalker
saga and his design seem acutely aware
of what moments still play well with
fans today and it makes exploring the
trilogies again a delight it's outside
of the more tightly directed levels that
the skywalker saga falters each campaign
takes you to a variety of small but open
hubs littered with many side quests and
optional puzzles for you to solve i
spent a lot of my time messing around on
tatooine during my first handful of
hours while initially engaging the
content in these hubs quickly becomes
repetitive puzzle and quest structures
are recycled to supply some challenge in
obtaining many of the game's unlockable
items from new characters and ships to
individual pieces for micro builds
there's only so many times that looking
for a character in an area filled with
almost identically styled ones is fun
though which convinced me to rush
through these hubs during campaigns to
get back to the good stuff attempting to
stick with the campaign's core content
also shows how empty some objectives can
be especially when these same hubs are
used to bridge the slower moments in the
films there are a handful of times when
you travel to a planet and are forced to
walk slowly behind a character until you
reach a waypoint get treated to a short
cut scene and then are directed back off
world to progress the story there's a
whole section in episode one where
you're looking for the gunguns after
they've fled their underwater sea but
you must walk from the entrance to the
farthest point of the hub just to get
the prompt to leave the level and search
elsewhere it's clear that side content
is meant to entice you to poke around
these hubs more but once that allure has
worn off the way it breaks up the pacing
throughout each campaign is frustrating
what does make the back and forth
journey somewhat more enjoyable is the
additional time you get to spend
admiring the incredible detail that has
gone into each of these hubs mixing the
blocky aesthetic of lego with some
realistic backdrops the skywalker saga
is surprisingly breathtaking to admire
the lighting in particular is
drastically improved over previous
entries providing a sheen to the clean
minifig characters that can be visibly
dulled over time and under the right
conditions whether in the blinding white
snow storm of hoth or the dusty streets
of moss esper the heavy rain on camino
makes lightsaber swings glisten across
the water slicked surfaces setting a new
high bar for what you can expect from
future lego games of this ilk
[Music]
get down here much like the way early
lego star wars games set a tone for
where the franchise would explore next
and how it would do so the skywalker
saga feels like the epitome of all
lessons learned along the way while also
setting up for the future the intimate
new camera angle and expanded combat
breathe life into a familiar formula
while the linear levels feature a
pleasing mix of puzzles and combat that
are peppered with sharp humor it's a pe
that all of this can't be leveraged well
enough to inject the same excitement
into the side content that makes up most
of the explorable hubs which can take
the thrill out of the hunting down every
unlockable character but when the
skywalker saga finds its stride and it
often does it can be one of the most
enjoyable ways to rediscover this
storied franchise once again
you have done well lord vader and now i
said you wish to continue your search
for young
skywalker yes my master only together
can we turn into the dark shade of the
force
[Music]
you